thanks everyone okay let's continue
trying to destroy opponents and getting
reading I think I'm on the streak
haven't lost in a little bit try not
Kinks myself I've been white so many
games I still want to play a hedgehog
I wonder if here for chess feds is still
here let's play b3
it's the b3 French what is d4 every time
I play this opening I bow test gambit to
keep up the street let's play for that's
a move you'll preserve preserve the
vision looks interesting I want to play
c3 soon and just develop Thomas Mason
welcome back okay now the bishops happy
let's Castle d3 okay I'm pleased with
this position play h3 I have to manage
my time
Oh some Knights 95 ideas a5 let's play
rook e1 if here it takes takes Bishop d5
takes take solving the pawn in the end
each six all play Knight of fun
I'm at five squared
that's a nice square here for chess fans
is still here thanks
yeah don't go anywhere uh what to do
rook c1 maybe not sure what my plan is
maybe night eh for yeah I want to get to
f5 and eventually I want to vote s
gambit okay so the bishop if the bishops
taken I'll be happy as the bishop isn't
taking I'll be happy I think
that's tricky though mmm I don't really
want to play c4 but it's kind of
explosive actually have takes I'll take
with bishop and then keep the C file
half open yeah that's a move mmm I
should a three perhaps I also just sack
a bishop for nothing choices choices if
I sock a bishop and get nothing probably
not a great decision
I could play Queen d2 I'll play Queen d2
open then I sock a pawn for nothing
there's Bishop a three I'll play Bishop
III lock applying pressure I still want
to sack stuff for a questionable
compensation I'll play this move if my
takes b3 I have rook be one okay let's
take it's kind of annoying
mmm I don't want to trade Queens problem
[Music]
I might have to there there yeah Queen
b3 I'm allowing the Queen trade I don't
think we'll see a boat as gambit unless
something terrible happens maybe I'll
have to promote later I could play Queen
f3 okay
photos gambit still possible bishop see
one coming bishop c1 there's a rook fork
my bishop has very few squares oh but
Bishop g7 okay not happening let's play
this move I'm gonna say Bishop g7 Queen
c3 I could take let's play Bishop d2
waiting for the rook to come here so I
can skew her play this I want to play F
for a for systematic break but the rook
here we could trade rooks 41 seconds
it's taken them play off four
five I guess g5 could happen I could
second nights maybe and sacking a night
kind of looks fun um 5i5 also looks fun
also much fun to be had okay f6 man 9f5
and then each for hmm it's still
complicated reasonable move like Queen
e1 hitting g5 with Bishop 21 seconds
takes take your first where's my queen
sack for checkmates okay I want to play
Queen a5 and just sneak in from behind
I'm threatening this - to win this
okay blacks trying to attack I'm trying
to attack oboe test gave a possibility
Bishop f8 I'm trying I'm threatening
this don't see it play 93 yes the Queen
sac has returned check and mate oh so
beautiful so beautiful more YouTube
content Wow
people on you to smash the like button
or the love button there should be a
little button I'll see you in the future